les coups de feu de jeudi dans ce
quartier de dijon avait pris pour cible
dans son véhicule un habitant de chenôve
la victime n'a pas survécu à ses
blessures la voiture utilisée par le
tireur volée la veille avait été
retrouvé un peu plus tard dans la vallée
de l'ouche le passager de cette voiture
s'est constitué prisonnier à metz ce
week-end
ainsi qu'une autre personne suspectée
d'avoir apporté son aide et qui s'est
rendu à la police judiciaire de dijon
enfin le tireur présumé un dijonnais de
20 ans s'est donc présenté au
commissariat de beaune dimanche les
trois personnes ont été placées en garde
à vue le procureur de la république de
dijon donnera une conférence de presse
cet après midi